you
[Music]
in the second chapter but
of the ethics he brings up that politics
is the highest form of community and
then he explains that in various places
in the ethics but especially in a book
that he wrote called the politics the
ethics ends with a reference to politics
this moral concern this concern with the
good that we have is born according to
Aristotle in our capacity to talk which
involves seeing the good in things what
a thing is talking is the same thing as
thinking the Greek word for thinking and
talking is the same word it's the word
logos by the way which in the Gospel of
John verse 1 in the beginning was the
word that word is logos it's a big
important word right in in in theology
and in philosophy because your thinking
is unique among creatures among the
other creatures are not rational but you
can do it out loud if you have friends
or if you have spouses then one of the
things you'll think is you can just tell
them everything you think they can know
you so what arises from this gift of
reason first of all moral concern
interest in the good second of all a
radical kind of sociability and if you
put together orality and sociability
you get politics now we're gonna have
the ritual that we perform at Hillsdale
College in class what did we do last
time
and then everyone looks at his notes
Ryan so last time we started off by
talking about what is ethics and we
decided that it's the study of how best
to live and that involves character
which takes time to H it takes time to
develop and okay stop a minute didn't we
isolate that ethics is not the study of
anything it's a way to live and the
study is to find out what that is what
are you studying when you're studying
ethics what is the answer to that
character you said
what that mean yet you're in grave
sharing that's right something that gets
in you right do this to yourself real
hard right now you know right that push
you push push push you know it starts to
hurt that and then you'll remember that
longer than if you just done that and so
this character-building thing hard work
and requires a lot of preparation
because it's also a little bit like this
too if you like tried to build your
character with the chisel you'd kill
yourself you have to do it you have to
do it in materially right and you have
to do it a lot and over and over again
and we said what the purpose of ethics
is didn't we well it's to form the
character in accordance with the good
and the purpose of that well the good is
is beautiful so it's good for its own
sake so everything it's in order to
bring the human person into order with
to direct his action with the good or
towards it to be happy there we go
that's all of that that you just said is
summarized in the expression happiness
but we're gonna get there now you'll
find out by the way anybody who
undertakes a serious college education
will find out that much of the time and
much of the benefit is contained in
learning what words mean and we threw
around a bunch of big words last time
our inquiry choice the biggest of that
series good beautiful so now we need to
find out what those words mean also
human human person and we're gonna
define what that is right now okay so
we're gonna turn to a different book by
Aristotle it's called politics Gill tell
us what politics our politics is I don't
want to say study it ain't though
politics is
a communion of persons and with a common
end in a state we're talking about what
is good and advantageous and just okay
then had all the elements but it was a
little sloppy so put that in order for
us Steven can you do that I would just
say it's the things that have to do with
the political community when we talk
about those things we're talking about
politics and what is the political
community what is community and what
makes it political well a community is a
partnership and Aristotle tells us that
like human beings the community aims at
the good and the political community is
the highest kind of community somebody
reads the first sentence of chapter 1
book 1 of Aristotle's politics another
very great book since we see that every
city is some sort of community and that
every community is constituted for the
sake of some good for everyone does
everything for the sake of what is held
to be good it is clear that all
communities aim at some good and that
the community that is most authoritative
of all and embraces all the others does
so particularly and aims at the most
authoritative good of all this is what
is called the city or the political
community so remember we talked about
the arts and how they're arranged in a
hierarchy vital making bridle
horsemanship victory something beyond
victory because you could be victorious
and healthy we named healthy is another
thing good for its own sake you could be
victorious and healthy and still be
miserable so what would you add to those
and air sources there has to be some
ultimate or else there'd be an infinite
regression and I'll tell you what that
means it's a practical problem right and
it's one of the things that's shot
through with our way of thinking today
so it's an innovation of the last
hundred years and that is what we think
is there's different ultimate ends for
different human beings and that means
that because these things are so in such
an integrity in the way Aristotle
presents them
up and down it would mean that if you
started out and if the ultimate thing
were this or this then when you work
your way down you'd get to a different
place and that means none of this would
hold true so he's saying that just as
he's already said that the arts and the
goods are arranged in a hierarchy now he
introduces the fact that communities or
partnerships are also arranged in a
hierarchy and then this first sentence
also contains the information that if
you want to know definitively what a
thing is find out what it's for what
today meant that's not the whole of it
right but there are other causes of
things that contribute to the definition
of them but the authoritative one is
what's it for and he says that there's
lots of communities and they too are
arranged in a hierarchy according to
their ends the hierarchy of their ends
the ones that aim at higher goods are
better and the ones the payment the
ultimate good are best
yeah is that why he's calling it the
most authoritative good of all because
the political communities aiming at that
good that's going to order all
everything else that's right in and we
mustn't lose sight of the fact that
politics is authoritative in two senses
one is in every political community the
political community has a monopoly on
force you know it it's authoritative
like that give you orders shoot you if
you don't follow them if you get pulled
over for speeding and you refuse to get
pulled up to be pulled over if it goes
far far enough the military be after you
and they can probably get you
so it's authoritative that way but also
is one just said what you're saying is
then that there are some ends and other
ends are ordered toward them they give
those other ends their purpose and
therefore they have authority over them
they define what they are and this
community
is said to be the authoritative one now
we don't have time to read it in book
one today somebody sketch if you can
remember it how does he layout these
communities you know because remember he
lays out the arts shipbuilding for ships
and that for travel and navigation or
transported and Bridal linking for
bridles how do the communities how does
he lay them out and he lists the order
of them yeah right
he starts with the household and the
household begins with the male and
female who have children and then also
the master and the slave and has the
household exists for the fulfillment of
daily needs
okay Ryan said slave and so I should
make a point about that if you read the
olive book one we're not gonna do it
here you'll find out that Aristotle
actually says that slavery is just only
in the case of someone who is
incapacitated and unable to direct their
own lives and there are such people it's
not many and slavery is common in Athens
and it comes from conquest mostly when
you defeat somebody you can enslave them
which the Greeks did a lot and he
doesn't say that it's got to be
abolished overnight but he says that
it's wrong except in that case it's a
very important point to make and then he
says a very pregnant thing in here that
I'll just point out he says if the
shuttle could weave or the plectrum or
pick could strike of itself so in other
words if you could make cloth or you
could play music of themselves that
means a machine that does it
automatically then maybe this
relationship of master and slave would
not be needed in other words Aristotle
foresees a world in which technology
does all that stuff so about the slavery
thing just remember it's a kind of
attitude you have to adopt which is very
contrary to the prevailing attitude
today once you adopt the attitude that
you're going to find out the truth about
a thing important thing and the truth
doesn't depend on what you think mrs.
Ellis it's the truth about what you
think if you're going to try to find
that out and you're going to be serious
about that you're going to have to be
prepared to look everywhere and that
means back in the past - and of course
everywhere you look every single place
you look will be in the past because the
prison is an instant and the future is
unknown and so if it's a barrier that
Aristotle assumes that the household
will have slaves to understanding
Aristotle that's just one point to take
up and figure out what that does and
whether he's compromised by that and as
I say I told you what he said about it
I don't think Aristotle thought that
there was justice in human slavery
except in rare cases and so that's
because you mentioned that but now let's
go back to the more fundamental thing
than master and slave the relationship
in the household that's primary which
means first is what male and female and
why are they first I mean in order to
survive as a unit you have to have the
Union between the male and female and
the propagation of mankind that comes
from that marriage or to rephrase that
in order to have the male in the female
you're required to have the male and the
female we come to be through the family
and it exercises an influence on us
powerful influence on us right through
our lives and the Aristotle's point is
everything starts with that and that
gives us a really great possibility of
understanding this hierarchy again
because the family is primary you start
with that is it sufficient no why is it
not sufficient
on its own it just fulfills the needs of
daily life but it doesn't help one live
life well it the household turns into
the village when several households come
together
what's the village for I would say the
the village is a step above that but
it's not yet it's not yet the city so
list some things that the family can't
supply I come from Arkansas and they're
jokes about it but even there it's not
right to marry your sister so you need
some more faith you need some more
families around also families just a few
and for much of the life of the family
some of them are young and require
defense it's not a very defensible unit
it's in danger you can't really have
much trade in a family and so a whole
bunch of stuff spring to life and these
things mark you are naturally human
things that where nature comes from the
a Latin word that means birth so the
most natural relationship is the
reproductive relationship the way human
beings come to be and it's weird about
by the way human beings coming to be
because they take a long time to race
compared to other animals and yet we
have discretion of whether we do it or
not one of the elements and aspects of
our freedom and and yet it matters very
much even to us whether we do it or not
so there's that right and the family is
all wrapped up in that stuff and
everything starts with that stuff but
then right away a whole bunch of more
stuff is needed and when I'm as exchange
and one of them is defense and so you
get a village and then something is
added to that and it airs I was not
necessarily saying he can trace how one
develops and the next develops than the
next develops these communities are like
the goods that and the arts that we
examined they're arranged in a hierarchy
and so the family is very important and
then something is added that also in
the family in the village and then
finally the city
what's added there the city is the
partnership of villages and so the
villages can come together and because
of that the city can actually exist
itself it's self-sufficient and what
does it aim for living well happiness
so the virtues right law is a moral
phenomenon it's all about right and
right and wrong if you just ask yourself
grandly what is the good for which the
United States of America aims there's an
answer to that you couldn't speak
intelligently about that if you didn't
mention the debt course of Independence
which states then right but you know the
same thing is true of China what is the
good for which it aims well it's ruled
by a communist party that makes very
authoritative statements about that you
can read them here's what we're here to
do and for the good of our nation and
the world we few who are in control are
going to do those things and those are
different from America right Lincoln
said every nation has a central idea
from which all its minor thoughts
radiate in ours it's the principle of
human equality stated in the Declaration
of Independence so they're not all like
that though right and so when the city
comes together all of a sudden there's a
community that's making ultimate claims
it's very important we learn in the
course of this book Aristotle says that
the law is generally more influential
than your parents which is too bad in a
way if it's true but I think it is true
so it's a very powerful thing and it's
adopted by a people in a community that
carries the powers of life and death and
that's an old story it's true in America
as it was in Sparta okay so that's book
1 chapter 1 so we're going to skip ahead
to chapter 2
now we're gonna find out what we mean by
good and what we mean by human person
so somebody read that from these things
it is evident from these things that is
evident them that the city belongs among
the things that exist by nature and that
man is by nature a political animal he
who is without a city through nature
rather than chance is either a mean sort
or superior to man he is without clan
without law without hearth like the
person reproved by homer for the one who
is such by nature has by this fact a
desire for war as if he were an isolated
piece in a game of backgammon that man
is much more a political animal than any
kind of be or any herd animal as clear
ok stuff read that lessons again that
man is much more a political animal than
any kind of be or any herd animal is
clear that's dramatic isn't it these are
swarm animals everything is in common
radical division of labor among the
different ranks of the bees right
everything serves the queen the queen
serves everything else they do
everything together
in fact when they're flying they will
you know you see a swarm right and they
if they turn they all turn rarely
leaving one behind right we are more
political than that
so just remember how radical that is it
means that your political side of your
nature is embedded in you at least
equally as much as your kidneys or your
heart right that's the claim ok go ahead
and read for as we assert nature does
nothing in vain and man alone among the
animals has speech nature does nothing
in vain where's that mean Julia what do
you say it's essentially that in if we
have a capacity such as speech then it
has to be for some sort of guide or
first I'm sorry yeah there's some about
it right and and and man alone among the
animals
as speech a unique thing now the word
here is logos and Greek which means both
speech and reason go ahead the voice
indeed indicates the painful or pleasant
and hence is president other animals as
well for their nature has come this far
that they have a perception of the
painful and pleasant and indicate these
things to each other so this morning if
my wife stays in bed past about 7:45 the
dogs start talking to her and she knows
what they're saying they're saying
breakfast that's their point they want
something pleasure pain right they whine
if something hurts right and we all
understand my wife actually carries on a
dialogue all day long with the dogs and
yet in a practical sense they understand
her but not in another sense so go ahead
but speech serves to reveal the
advantageous and the harmful and hence
also the just and the unjust for as
peculiar to man as compared to the other
animals that he alone has a perception
of good and bad and just and unjust and
other things of this sort and
partnership in these things is what
makes a household and a city so do you
notice the occurrence in the word of the
word good in that sentence we perceive
the good and that's why we can talk the
claim is there's something we see all
the time and everything we see that
other animals don't see and that is what
makes us unique and that is what makes
us political speech which also means
however reason makes us unique and
political now you can see why speech
would make us social we can talk to each
other right but what are we doing when
we talk that involves understanding the
good oh because like we're
each human being is pursuing an end like
we have to talk to each other about what
we're going to do yeah it's a more basic
than that more than immediate more
immediate yeah Julia well since speech
is connected to reason we're able to
like actually reason about via speech
it's some sort of abstract gate that
work or yeah it's some sort of bit that
we are aiming for either as a community
or an individual how do we uh I was
blessed with a really great teacher and
one of the best things he understood and
could explain
he knew his Ariston was how does it come
to be that we use common nouns how can
we do that his claim is there's a
miracle in that that's parallel to the
miracle of creation yeah everything's
too uniform around here right so pinpin
right and you get a fountain pen you've
got one yeah it's pretty good so they're
different right this is the Lummi Safari
do you like pens I do how did Martin
Gilbert wrote much of the official
biography Winston Churchill was the
Lummi safari really they were all over
the place right
is this a Mont Blanc I couldn't tell you
yeah yeah it could be a knockoff yeah
probably why'd you graduates didn't even
have any money see they're different how
do you know and yet you know you can say
to somebody in another room where
neither of you can see what you're
instructing the person to do would you
please go and get me a pin on my desk
and they got no idea what the thing's
gonna look like when they get there but
they always find it this is light work
for human beings this is automatic but
and nobody ever teaches us to do it well
there's about two years old we all start
talking right and no other being ever
does you know we have four children we
didn't teach them to talk they just
started talking you know and in our
family the children are raised just like
the dogs for the first two
here's live on the floor eat the food on
the floor you know handy but then they
start talking and six months later they
live in a richly populated world
elephants bees horses know everything
somehow they can do that and the dogs
never do right they're still stupid
that's their charm by the way so
Aristotle says that's how we see good
things are defined by their purpose and
the point is this does this they're a
little bulky these ones yeah I know
and this is a fine point right yeah yeah
you're very precise young man so so the
point is it's it you know it it does
this and this that's yours
this does this and this does the same
thing except it's hot that's got a
little cool magnetic top on the top so
so that's their purpose they're good at
it they become hard to recognize if
they're harmed in a way that defeats the
purpose so the imaginary water bottle
with the bottom cut out it's not a good
one anymore
it's lost the being to the good and the
being Aircel rights are convertible
terms where you can use one in a
sentence you can use the other one good
cup being a cup good book being of the
book right good glasses being of the
glasses the basis of all human speech is
the common noun and every time we
identify one we are identifying the good
and the being of a thing and when it
says in the first sentence of this that
the good is that at which all things aim
he's claiming that there's a propriety
and satisfaction in each thing being
fully what it is and a bad thing
is only a good thing spoiled Mark Twain
golf he said a good walk spoiled
[Laughter]
apologies to the golfers but uh but you
see the thing that makes you what you
are and makes you more political than
horses and bees is this ability to
perceive and use the common noun from
which all language comes so then how
does that sorry
how does not relate to talking about the
human good though because like you were
with the examples we've been talking
about they're all man-made things
artificial things so it's kind of like
very clear to know what their being or
their purposes because we've given it to
them in a sense and so then how does
that relate to like perceiving of human
beings because we can see that these are
all human beings because they're good in
some way so there's an explicit
statement in the ethics about this
Aristotle says you know if there's a way
for the beings to be good a horse or
anything else must be some way like that
for a human what do you want a horse to
be like well there's different kinds of
good horses
Secretariat probably the greatest
racehorse I am - I like horses I like
the fact that they I don't know much
about horses now I have horses but
horses love to run and they're beautiful
when they run and so their ability to do
that that's what's awesome right if you
if you think that the word education
means lead fourth watch a horse go
forward and then watch it go backwards
it's not very good at that
well the point is if you can see that
about a horse you can see it about a
person and just like in the horses just
like the mayor pretty she's a pretty
white horse is you know gentle and all
that and something really good about
that right serves one of the functions
of a horse even if you might be able to
isolate the highest fine
which this book is going to say there
are many functions for a human being and
many of worth but that doesn't mean that
there's not one that highest and we're
going to isolate what that is and living
in the light of that ultimate one
Aristotle is going to claim even if you
can't fully participate in it will
improve and ennoble your life at
whatever level you live it because by
the way if you're interested in
fathoming and holding the good and the
true and the beautiful once you start
valuing that kind of thing to know what
beautiful things are to appreciate and
contemplate their beauty to develop
wisdom which is the accumulation of
knowledge about ultimate things and
takes time the next thing you know is
you become aware of things that really
do give purpose and direction to your
life you see and then Aristotle is going
to say before we're done that if you
practice up through these immediate and
sometimes small virtues every day in a
way to build your character finally you
will get yourself to a place where you
can hold your soul in attention and you
see truly the things that are happening
outside you and you are not in the way
anymore your wishes and your want are
not the thing now now you are looking at
things as they are and seeing the truth
and the beauty and the good in them
which means also seeing when it's there
the ugliness and the flaw in them and
the falseness in them you see and to see
the world as it is you actually have to
cultivate these moral virtues that are
the next thing in order to get yourself
into a state of patience and attention
where you can put your energy into doing
each thing before you not just the
really great moment or
you get to read something or see
something that's beautiful and live in
harmony with it for a time but also the
regular moments
Chesterton draws a picture Samuel
Johnson very similar of a well-ordered
human soul and how it looks to others
see you slows does this too actually and
he says one way it looks is when you're
talking with that person they seem
untroubled and attentive and they're not
unfriendly and yet they're judging and
listening and they're looking for a
chance to help to teach to learn right
and that's somebody who's got their life
in order and the point is that takes
practice a long time I have to really
commit to it but it's great to do
you